so they blew up the starbridge
yeah
violence
is the last refuge of the incompetent
hey guys pete here this will be my
breakdown of foundation season 1 episode
9. the first crisis is the penultimate
episode of the first season and it
featured a lot of movement towards
answering questions and resolving
storylines which means that things seem
pretty set up for the finale brother
dawn's secret is out salvor is starting
to internalize her father's wisdom
putting her on a path to become more
like her namesake in the book and the
vault has opened i'll be discussing all
of these things after this quick spoiler
warning if you haven't watched episode 9
yet then this video won't be for you and
with that out of the way let's get
started
so we'll start with brother dawn he
doesn't want to be killed and replaced
so he's meeting and planning with azor
to get out of there and we learn that
he's planning on leaving tomorrow and
that he'll need a signal damper for the
nanobots in his bloodstream he gets
summoned to meet with dusk at the mural
they talk about how it captures their
legacy he mentions some of the different
scenes including the end of the robot
wars the golden horse rebellion and the
attack on anacrion and thespis that we
saw in the opening episodes he's brought
him there because he's added their hunt
to the mural and he's done this as a
setup to test him to see if he's
colorblind he asked if he can see the
three ghillie raptors that he shot and
since he can only see the blue ones he
says yes after dusk leaves he uses the
corrected device that azure gave him and
he realizes that her six and now he's
sure that dusk knows he's different he
rushes in to pack a bag and leave but
before he can get out of there
shadowmaster obrecht comes in saying
that brother dusk needs to see him right
away he tries unsuccessfully to talk his
way out of it and then he has to use his
aura which also has a weapon mechanism
to knock out the shadow master and then
escapes to the garden and this escape
sequence it seemed a little bit funny
whenever i watched it the first time i
guess it all makes sense in the end that
they were letting him go because it felt
kind of hard to believe that he was able
to get out at all he does though he has
this dramatic sequence that involves
this water reservoir and he makes his
way outside the palace he's on his own
he's freezing and he trades the only
thing he has of value which is his aura
to one of the people that lives down
there for his jacket from there he's
able to make his way to the scar azura's
neighborhood by remembering what she
told him about it and he eventually
finds where she lives she welcomes him
and tells him not to worry that she's
installed the signal damper so he
doesn't have to worry about being found
and tells him to take a shower after he
goes in he has an idea about the new
name that he's gonna take and he comes
back out to find her with a gun in her
hand and she takes a shot he's able to
get outside of the apartment but he's
pursued by a group of goons and then
he's captured by himself he looks up to
see someone that looks exactly like him
when he wakes up he sees that his
imperial nanobots are being transferred
to a different clone who was raised
outside the palace he explains to him
that someone was able to smuggle some of
cleon's dna out and they've been working
on this plan for decades it's a
coordinated effort azura was part of it
and it seems like someone powerful would
have to be behind it because they're
playing a long game here and they have
access he explains all this with a
british accent so you can tell them
apart which is kind of funny but he
shows him that he's been practicing that
he can copy him exactly and the plan is
for him to replace the original dawn
they altered his dna after the fact so
that he would become different and the
replacement is an exact copy the reason
that they altered the dna was because
they needed to get him out of the palace
they wanted to orchestrate a reason for
him to run on his own fearing for his
own survival and when the nanobot
transfer is complete we see that the new
clone heals immediately so now he's
basically just a normal person and has
outlived his usefulness
but as i mentioned earlier they let don
get away so they could follow him to
these people and so dusk in the
shadowmaster and a group of soldiers
swoop in for a rescue fakedon is killed
shadowmaster obrecht uses that cloaking
device that we saw earlier in the season
to sneak up behind and cut his throat
azor has taken prisoners so they can
interrogate her and dust says that he
wants a memory audit done on all of the
dead people in the room after they lead
azor away dusk explains that they would
be able to overlook that but the matter
of his difference is rather more
complicated don looks at it like he's a
victim there was a conspiracy and it's
not his fault that he's been altered but
i mean come on that's why they have the
backups this has been his dilemma the
whole time he's a reminder of their
vulnerability and thus basically says
what logic is there to keep him around
brother dawn pleads for him to forget
logic and try empathy and in the end
it's not up to dusk anyways it's up to
brother day and he'll be back soon and i
suppose that it'll boil down to how he's
feeling after his showdown with the
luminists
on the foundation side of things we see
a flashback to a young salvor talking to
her dad she asked them where they came
from and they talk about the origins of
humanity humans are thought to have
inhabited a single system but they don't
remember which anymore he throws out the
idea of series alpha centauri and says
that some people think we came from some
place called earth all of this is
leading to questions about enacrion's
investments too how they're all humans
and they all came from the same place so
then how come they hate them so much her
father tells her that rational thinking
shares skull space with our emotions and
sometimes the emotions went out millions
of people died when the star bridge came
down and then the empire killed millions
more and who won and he brings out that
trademark phrase violence is the last
refuge of the incompetent and he's using
all of this to make the point that this
is how they know the empire's gonna fall
past behavior is the best predictor of
future performance salvor was able to
stay awake for the jump just as gail was
able to when she traveled to trantor
from synax it turns out that they did
make it back to terminus because lewis
connected himself to the navigation and
got them there after he was shot and of
course he didn't survive since she's the
only one that's awake and she can't get
a hold of anyone on terminus she ends up
leaving the invictus doing a spacewalk
to get back to her ship while she's
there she reunites with hugo and they
realize the null field is probably why
they can't reach anyone on the planet he
makes a suggestion that they just run
away from it all but she says that she
needs to fix this and so he goes back to
the invictus and because she's immune to
the null field she heads towards the
planet on the surface it turns out they
were right everyone's knocked out and so
salvor heads to the vault there she
finds her mother passed out with the
prime radiant in her hand she takes that
and she concentrates and through
memories actually gail's memories she
remembers how to open it and when she
does the vault reacts it opens and the
null field is lifted people are starting
to wake up on the invictus when hugo and
the thesmans arrived they couldn't find
farah it turns out she's boarding one of
those thespian lancers and takes control
of it and at this point everyone's
heading towards the surface salvor moves
towards the vault and her mother tries
to stop her but then the anacrions fire
a warning shot that's followed by the
thesman ships arriving everyone on board
starts to come out and these ships have
this thing where the captain can
remotely control the firepower and so
that's enough to get the anacrions to
stand down
salvor believes this is where she's
supposed to be she sees everything
converging in a single crisis and things
get more intense when pharah arrives in
that lancer and destroys the other ones
that were already there she has the same
remote control device for the ship so
that gets the thesmans to stand down and
she wants to kill salvor who tries to
convince her that the invictus is the
most powerful ship that they'll ever get
their hands on so why destroy it why not
use it for leverage
she makes the suggestion that they all
band together and then she draws off her
father's words saying let our logic
speak louder than our emotions pharah's
soldiers are receptive to this and rowan
tells her that the hunt is over then
something like a bolt of lightning
shoots out of the vault and farah
decides that shooting it with her ship
seems like the best course of action
this isn't something that salvore can
let happen so she uses the grand
his bow to kill her which increases
tensions with everyone but then they're
all taken aback when harry seldon walks
out of the vault he says well this is
encouraging enacrions thespins and
termini seeing you all gathered here
gives me hope we might actually pull
this off and the episode ends there
so this definitely felt like we're
getting somewhere on the brother dawn
side of this he wanted the genetic
dynasty to forget about logic and try
empathy on the foundation side salvor
advocated for letting rational thought
speak louder than emotion brother dawn
is still a problem he's different but he
does come from the dynasty he was raised
by them educated by them and still by
their own code they should destroy him
the one character who was driven purely
by emotion who based on her past was
compelled towards revenge against the
empire met her end and we'll have to
wait and see if dawn suffers the same
fate there's a parallel there farrah
couldn't see beyond that thing that
drives her that defined her and it will
be interesting to find out if brother
day is able to do that i have to say i'm
kind of happy that the pharah story is
over and it appears that harry selden
anticipated that there would be conflict
this is consistent with what his
character did in the books only here it
seems like he was counting on these
three factions coming together all to be
part of this new foundation so we got
there in a different way but it seems
like the terminus side of things is
going to start to be more like the
original story based on everything that
we've seen here salvor is an evolving
character and it seems likely that
she'll take everything that she's
learned from this experience to emerge
as the leader of the foundation going
forward this is one of those situations
where watching that saga feature that
they put out a couple of weeks ago kind
of spoiled the invictus storyline
because i saw that i was pretty sure
they were going to jump straight back to
terminus but i thought it was a fair
ending for the lewis character and they
handled it pretty well he was able to
see past his own mistakes get behind
salmore and ultimately he saved the
foundation the brother dawn and azor
conclusion was a pretty big surprise i
thought she seemed suspicious a couple
of episodes back but they did a pretty
good job of selling the fact that the
relationship was organic that it
happened naturally that she was actually
into him and it's not hard to see how he
got caught up in it i suppose the most
popular theory was that demarzel might
be behind what happened to the clones
because of her proximity to the program
and her general mysteriousness i imagine
that could still be the case but it's
kind of exciting that there is another
force out there that's making trouble
for the cleons i think the scope of this
operation hints that there's a lot more
to explore there and i kind of doubt
that we'll get any reveals about who's
behind it by the end of the first season
we have a lot of mysteries swirling
around the connection between salvor and
gail she definitely saw her memories and
used that to open the prime radiant we
didn't see any gale at all this episode
but i saw on apple tv that she is the
thumbnail for the next one so maybe
we'll get some more answers who's
responsible for altering dawn and will
that turn out to be related to the
starbridge attack there really isn't an
answer to what happened there yet how
will brother day respond to dawn's
differences when he learns about them is
there something more to the invictus and
why it became a ghost ship 700 years ago
there's still that message of exo exo to
consider there it was nice to see harry
make an appearance on terminus i had
been waiting for that to happen and that
brings up questions about if there's a
difference between the hologram gale was
talking to on the raven and the one we
see here there's also a question of how
the vault got there in the first place
one of the things the original
foundation trilogy explores is related
to what abba said to young salvor past
behavior is the best predictor of future
performance asimov based his galactic
empire on the fall of rome because
generally speaking humanity tends to not
learn from its mistakes the idea of
history repeating itself or that it
doesn't repeat itself but it often
rhymes if you prefer that one even tens
of thousands of years in the future
people are still people and that's where
the idea of psycho history comes in
now we'll have to wait until next week
to see what else harry has to say about
his plan to the future foundation i
guess for where we're at it's promising
that he seems pleased with what's going
on even after pharaoh was blasting the
vault and trying to destroy it it
appears that things are falling into
place and i'm looking forward to seeing
how they wrap things up next week and i
think that's a great place to leave
things let me know in the comments what
you thought about episode 9 what you're
hoping to see in the finale and anything
else you got on your mind about
foundation i will have another
foundation video out this week i've been
working on something but i wanted to
wait until this episode dropped so check
back for that and please like this video
if you enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon